michel sapin le ministre du travail est
l'invité de preuve par trois moments
clefs et même tendu on peut le dire du
réformisme social
cette orientation revendiqué par le
quinquennat qui ne fait pas le bonheur
michel sapin de toute votre majorité
cela alors que la rue est occupée
bruyamment par les victimes des plans de
licenciements ont regroupé derrière la
cgt et fo pour réclamer une autre
politique pour vous interroger et je le
sois pas nous rejoindrons tour à tour
sur ce plateau pierre glachant de l'
agence france-presse notre partenaire
pour preuve par trois partenaires avec
dailymotion d'ailleurs depuis quinze
jours qui permet aux internautes bien de
réagir en direct à cette émission et
même de vous interpeller
et puis également péri tarnos sera là à
nous rejoindre à perrine tarneaud de
public sénat qui est intrigué par votre
statut de valeur sûre du gouvernement ça
ne veut pas dire qu'elle le conteste
mais d'abord que répondez-vous à la cour
des comptes sur l'impossibilité de
réduire à 3% le déficit public cette
année d'ailleurs on note que françois
hollande fait un premier pas dans son
sens en évoquant une révision à la
baisse de la croissance
ce que souligne la cour des comptes je
crois que c'est le principal c'est
l'effort que en ce moment le
gouvernement mais en général sous
l'impulsion du président la réplique
fait pour redonner un équilibre à nos
comptes publics ce qui avait été perdu
pour diminuer les déficits ce qui sera
le cas et pour diminuer l'endettement de
la france est cet effort là qu'il faut
continuer qu'il faut maintenir dans le
temps mais ça c'est pas dramatique mais
c'est quand même la cour des comptes
n'est jamais là pour donner des
satisfecits
mais je remarque simplement que sur ce
point elle dit que l'effort a été
programmé que l'effort est tenue pour ce
qu'ils étaient poursuivis et que cet
effort est nécessaire c'est ce que nous
faisons
on fait pas pour le plaisir on le fait
simplement parce que il n'est pas
possible de continuer à rembourser temps
de dette étant d'intérêt de la dette
alors qu'il ya tant de besoins par
ailleurs à satisfaire et à financer et
donc on nous prenons nos responsabilités
mais parce qu'il a passé ces faits par
les uns et par les autres auparavant
nous le faisons aujourd'hui mais il ne
servirait
à rien je lui dis très clairement
aujourd'hui de faire une course à
l'austérité supplémentaire quitte à ce
qu'à ce moment là on casse les ressorts
qui sont les ressorts de la croissance
qui va venir qui est en train d'être
construites nous construisons les bases
nécessaires pour un retour de la
croissance nous le construisons niveau
européen avec une politique de stabilité
au niveau européen dont nous
construisons en france on en parlera
certainement avec une banque publique
d'investissement avec ce crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi pour les
entreprises pour qu'elles investissent
pour que les innove faut qu'elle en
boucle et avec une nouvelle
réglementation dans le domaine du droit
du travail pour faire sauter cette peur
de l' embauche qui aujourd'hui bloc
un certain nombre d'emplois entendu
aussi les critiques de la cour des
comptes qui dit que bien il ya passé
l'économie on les voit pas dans le
budget et puis que vous vous reposez sur
des hausses d'impôts donc aléatoire
vous dites pas de course supplémentaire
à l'austérité ça veut dire que les 3% de
déficit sont pour vous un dogme qu'il
faudrait dépasser vu la conjoncture
c'est l'objectif de la france elle l'a
réaffirmé c'est un engagement qui est
pris vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
européens
c'est une question européenne et cette
question là se reposer au niveau
européen elle ne concerne pas que la
france elle concerne l'ensemble de nos
partenaires européens
mais je le répète le 3 % je veux pas
rentrer technique c'est le résultat
c'est le résultat d'une règle de trois
et donc c'est ce qui compte vraiment
pour tout le monde et d'ailleurs c'est
ce que dit le fmi
ce que dit le c d e ce que dit la
commission ce que dit aujourd'hui la
cour des comptes c'est que l'effort que
nous faisons qui est un effort de
justice fiscale
certains nous le reproche de justice
fiscale et qui est un effort de maîtrise
et de diminution de nos dépenses
publiques nous puissions le continuer au
rythme que nous avons revu viendra c'est
3% mais c'est le répète de 3% et le
résultat d'un calcul mais tu es
maintenant ce qui compte c'est que nous
avions prévu 35 milliards de diminution
des déficits publics
il y aura ces 35 milliards de diminution
du département et sur la tendance mais
jean françois copé lui considère que la
cour des comptes privés par votre ami
monsieur migaud confirme les critiques
de l'ump contre françois hollande
mp qui a mis la france dans la situation
dans laquelle nous l'avons trouvée a
vraiment peu de leçons à donner
donc laissons ces critiques la leçon de
caractère politicien qui est beaucoup
plus important c'est qu'elle est fort de
quelle manière est il partagé entre les
français c'est pour ça que nous avons
fait une réforme fiscale qui fait que
certains payent plus d'impôts est en
partie les plus riches des français qui
fait que nous avons fait des réformes
pour que les revenus du capital soient
imposés comme les revenus du travail
c'est pas si simple que cela
les formes que ça fait réagir ou la vue
non mais il faut de la justice dans
l'appel à l'effort et il faut en même
temps
du sérieux dans la dépense mais je le
répète ça ne servirait à rien comme
d'autres pays ont été obligés de le
faire de courir comme ça tout le temps
tout le temps à moins dépenser moins de
dépenses moins dépenses
on sait que dans ces cas là c'est un
effet sur la croissance et donc cette
cette spirale à la baisse qui a abouti à
ce qu'un pays comme la grèce tombe dans
la situation au lait ça n'est pas la
situation de la france et ça ne sera pas
la situation de la france nous
continuons avec le même chemin avec la
même constance avec la même volonté de
rééquilibre de nos comptes publics
vainqueur voilà qui est bien notée donc
c'est votre réponse à la cour des
comptes michel sapin il ya des critiques
dans la rue également un et que répondez
vous aujourd'hui tous ceux qui sont
mobilisés autour des goodyear et ce
tease
pour résumer berner par les illusions
social dispensés pendant la campagne
présidentielle vous êtes salarié d'une
entreprise comme goodyear et surtout du
site du goût dit hier amy adore et qu'on
vous annonce du jour au lendemain que ça
va fermer et qui va y avoir le plus de
1000 emplois supprimés et éventuellement
1000 licenciements il ya de quoi être en
colère il ya de quoi manifester entre le
sa colère et il ya de quoi le faire en
tant qu leur par exemple contre la cgt
il ya de quoi le faire là où ils l'ont
fait c'est à dire devant la direction de
goodyear au moment où une réunion est en
cours d'un comité central d'entreprise
c'est-à-dire d'un lieu de négociations
et de discussions parce qu'il faut
appuyer les négociations qui vont
commencer sur cette question parce que
je le répète il est normal qu'une
organisation syndicale ou surtout des
salariés dans la détresse
10 au gouvernement fait quelque chose
pour nous ils sont tout seul maintenant
que je puisse lancer retirer nam et il
n'y a pas que titan heureux au monde il
y en aura d'autres qui fabrique des qui
peuvent fabriquer des pneus donc il faut
bien entendu accompagné toutes les
possibilités de recherche mais je veux
simplement dire que l'interlocuteur
d'une organisation syndicale dans une
entreprise c'est la direction de cette
entreprise
la modalité qu'il faut pousser qu'il
faut même poussé plus qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la négociation dans l'entreprise
il faut donc donner au dialogue social
dans l'entreprise toutes ses chances si
ce dialogue social avait été menée de
manière pertinente et de manière
suffisamment dans les royal direction a
good year il y aurait eu une solution
l'année dernière ça n'a pas été le cas
et on voit où se retrouvent aujourd'hui
est clair c'est par le dialogue social
ces deux vers 5h parce que là la cfdt
par exemple de cette usine a critiqué la
cgt d'un gars bloqué sur cette
organisation syndicale qui étonne dans
le débat syndical avec d'autres
organisations syndicales moi je suis le
ministre du travail
je prends toutes les ambitions syndicale
avec respect ne pas dire que je suis
d'accord avec elles ou qu'elles sont
d'accord avec moi mais je les prends
tout cas calé sur glace une autre pas
une organisation syndicale du doigt je
dis simplement que le dialogue social
dans cette entreprise
s'il avait fonctionné on n'en serait pas
là aujourd'hui voilà bon vous voulez pas
exactement définir les responsabilités
des uns et des autres nous a quand même
un peu compris michel sapin néanmoins le
futur patron de la cgt monsieur thierry
le paon va lui jusqu'à jugé que françois
hollande s'inscrit dans la suite de
nicolas sarkozy à qu'est ce que vous me
répondez comme le disait un autre
ministre du gouvernement qui a de
l'expérience
chronologiquement c'est vrai françois
hollande après niveau là
donc hollande pour un sarkozy que vous
leur aval c'est d'abord un coup pour le
reste je pense que il fait une erreur en
laissant penser que ce que penserait ses
propres troupes
elles savent bien qu'il ya eu un
changement elle voit bien que ce ne sont
pas non seulement des différences de
personnes des différences d'attitude
mais sont aussi des différences de
politiques et que ce que nous
construisons pas à pas et qui par
définition ne peut pas avoir un effet
immédiat goodyear est un problème grave
depuis de quatre ans donc il suffit pas
de changer de président de la république
pour que les problèmes graves de
goodyear depuis quatre ans ce réseau ils
le savent très bien
les propres troupes de monsieur le pan
savent parfaitement que les choses vont
changer
ensuite qu'on soit un patient qu'on en
veuille plus qu on veut que ça aille
plus vite que ça va être plus fort c'est
normal ça fait partie du jeu
démocratique et ça fait partie du
dialogue social entre le gouvernement et
l'ensemble des organisations c'est ce
qu'on peut dire que les plans sociaux
pèse finalement assez peu sur les
chiffres de pôle emploi aujourd'hui
c'est la réalité la bière fait
statistique quel pourcentage des entrées
on peut considérer aujourd'hui que sur
100 chômeurs qui rentrent chez eux
chaque mois à pôle emploi
il y en a pas quatre qui sont chômeurs à
la suite d'un plan social mais ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il faut s'occuper de
tout le reste ça veut dire qu'il faut
s'occuper des 90% consciente au chômage
c'est pas du tout seule chose qui
l'intéressé des plans sociaux ni bien
entendu de ces grands plans de
licenciements qui ont un effet massif à
la fois pour les salariés mais aussi
pour les régions concernées
je dis pas ça pour me leurrer mais je
dis ça parce que nos politiques contre
le chômage doivent être des politiques
qui sont tournés vers les 90 % qui sont
quoi des fins de cdd des fans missions
d'intérim des jeunes qui arrivent sur le
marché du travail et qui ne trouvent pas
leur emploi des femmes qui reviennent
sur le marché du travail et qui ne
trouvent pas d'emploi
sais tu as tout cela qu'il faut aussi
apporter une réponse plus amusé les
invisibles mais c'est pas une raison
pour ne pas s'en occuper
au contraire alors faut s'occuper de ses
90 % comme il faut bien entendu avoir
une attention particulière pour aider
appuyé accompagner ceux qui aujourd'hui
cherchent des solutions dans des
entreprises qui ont des plans massifs de
licenciement
venir les plans de licenciements est ce
que le chef de l'état fait la moitié du
chemin seulement en ajoutant à la jambe
l'agenda parlementaire il d'annoncer une
loi sur la reprise des sites rentables
mais il ne parle plus de la loi sur les
licenciements boursiers qui réclamait
dans la rue là aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucune de nouvelles particulières aucune
surprise dans l'annoncé du présent la
pluie c'est quelque chose qui depuis
depuis toujours a été dit il est clair
d'ailleurs que c'est une proposition de
loi à l'initiative du groupe socialiste
qui est en cours d'élaboration et qui
permettra d'apporter des réponses à ces
situations intolérables où vous avez une
entreprise qui marche avec un site qui
marche qui gagnent de l'argent je parle
pas d'un site mais comme goodyear tu
perds de l'argent ainsi qu'ils gagnent
de l'argent et il se dit si je vais le
déplacer ailleurs je veux en gagner
encore plus et bien dans ces cas là il
doit y avoir la possibilité nous verrons
suivant quelle méthode pour qu'une autre
offre une autre entreprise qui veut
racheter ce site rentable puisque de la
fiction
si oui où l'on condamné à la fermeture
par leur propriété sur le jeu lancé j'ai
le sentiment que c'est le cas où ce
fabricant de glaces il pas qui a
aujourd'hui décidé de fermer pour aller
voir ailleurs alors qu'ils gagnent de
l'argent sur celui-ci vous exproprier le
là on regarde regardera le mener de les
modalités c'est tout ça qui est en train
d'être discutées par le groupe
socialiste mais il faut répondre à ces
situations qui sont intolérables
de même que ce qu'on appelle les
licenciements boursiers alors par
l'actionnaire doit avait pas du tout ces
bandes l'accord paraît qu'on va en
parler dans quelques minutes
adacore l'accord oui c'est drôle c'est
prévu dans l'accord entre les
partenaires sociaux et c'est prévu dans
le projet de loi puisque maintenant il
s'agit d'un projet de loi d'un avant
projet doivent en parler sur ce donc ces
produits-là y est je peux vous expliquer
comment on luttera contre les
licenciements boursiers grâce à la mise
en oeuvre de l'accord du 11 janvier qui
est un très bon accord pour les salariés
domaine quel commentaire vous inspire
monsieur l'ex mittal qui a boycotté
apparemment enfin qui n'était pas
présent à une réunion importante à
bruxelles on va évoquer le plan européen
pour la sicile à une réunion des
ministres et l'industrie à bruxelles qui
se préoccupent de l'acier européen pas
seulement de l'acier dans chacun de
leurs pays en et l'acier européen
je pense qu'effectivement la moindre des
choses c'est que le premier aciériste
européen puisqu'il
c'est le premier fabricant d'acier en
europe auraient dû être présents à leur
demande
cette mauvaise aventure collabos que
c'est une désinvolture qui aurait pu
être évitée voilà le message est passé
par la prochaine fois le dialogue c'est
toujours meilleur que le fait de tourner
les talons
parce que le pari reste toujours
d'inverser la courbe du chômage à la fin
de l'année c'est un pari on joue pas
mais je n'ai pas mis de l'argent sur la
table
c'est un engagement c'est un objectif
mobilisateur
nous devons inverser la confiance à dire
très simplement tout notre combat
économique financier budgétaire avec
toutes les réglementations nouvelles
dans le domaine du travail tout est
politique nouvelle dans le domaine de
l'emploi est fait pour qu'on inverse la
machine qui peut passer un peu comme
pour la baisse de données si je vous dis
alors vous vous penchez vous croyez qu'à
une seule chose c'est à l'augmentation
continue irréversible et pour toujours
du chômage n'ont donc vous souhaitez
vous aussi individuellement et
collectivement qu'on arrête la montée du
chômage et qu'on avait recensé dans
votre fonds de roulement que votre
obligation c'est de donner de l'espoir
mais c'est pas seulement donné l'espoir
pourquoi seulement de perdre espoir
c'est pourquoi des seulement des pertes
allemand paraît parité ouais c'est ça
compte peut-être mais romero n'a pas une
élection devant nous là il n'ya pas eu
d'élections en 2013 je pense à une
promesse pour passer par dessus une
élection je suis en train avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement de mettre en
place des outils qui seront efficaces
qu'ils sont efficaces qui commença et
efficace mais qui vont avoir leur pleine
efficacité à la fin de cette année et à
la fin de cette année oui nous aurons
inverser la courbe du chômage
oui vous le répéter donc vous aurez
inverser la courbe du chômage à la fin
de l'année michel sapin voilà exactement
c'est clair c'est comme ça que nous
pouvons mobiliser l'ensemble des acteurs
parce que c'est pas simplement l'arrière
d'un ministre c'est la sphère de tous
les ministres et palop simplement la
sphère d'un gouvernement c'est la sphère
de tous les acteurs économiques que ce
soit du côté patronal comme du côté
syndical
et pour cela donc vous avez notamment
les emplois d'avenir vous avez les
contrats de génération et puis donc cet
accord sur la compétitivité des
entreprises et une certaine sécurisation
de l'emploi curité des salariés qui va
devenir une loi elle sera présentée au
conseil des ministres début mars un
texte qui a donc été acceptée par le
patronat et par une partie des syndicats
majoritaires majoritaire 3 la tâche vous
revient donc maintenant ça va être
compliqué là pour les semaines qui
viennent
sa femme est plus compliqué c'était de
retranscrire dans la loi c'est pas fini
c'est pas fini parce que maintenant il
va falloir préserver ce fragile
équilibre
face aux coups de boutoir ils sont
nombreux dans votre majorité des rites
war ii qui de la bonne note et attend
les coûts de gauche du ps ont voisard
connaît pas on en parle dans un instant
après cette mise au point faite par
fabrice q mais sur le texte de cet
accord sur l'emploi
tout juste déposé devant le conseil
d'état est déjà menacé de modification
l'avant projet de loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi fait toujours
débat au sein de la majorité malgré des
retouches apportées après un mois de
tractations dans les coulisses du
ministère du travail
d'ailleurs des débats qui dépasse
largement ce qu'on appelle
historiquement l'ailé gauche car
beaucoup des députés prenant
connaissance du texte se rendre compte
quand même qu' il y à a de gros
problèmes qui peuvent se poser aux
salariés de leur circonscription où je
crois qu'au sein du parti socialiste
la volonté d'un amendement est
certainement plus large qu'on le croit
un sentiment partagé par les syndicats
non signataires de l'accord des
syndicats
bien décidé à faire pression sur les
parlementaires la partie n'est pas
terminée sur cette affaire et on a connu
des situations où l'intervention à la
mobilisation des salariés a fait bouger
les lignes et concret d'un projet de loi
dans ce parcours législatif qui commence
le gouvernement pourra compter sur le
soutien de parlementaires ump à l'image
de gérard larcher
l'ancien ministre du travail connaît la
difficulté de l'exercice et jugent
l'accord équilibré
j'ai bien noté dans le passé c'était la
même chose que les deux syndicats cgt
force ouvrière qui n'ont pas signé on
quand même participé à la rédaction de
la transcription j'allais dire en mode
législatif de projet de loi de l'accord
entre les partenaires sociaux
attention la posture attention aux jeux
de rôles qui naturellement le texte qui
nous vient après l'assemblée nationale
est un texte qui respecte l'esprit et la
lettre des accords je voterai
cet accord des partenaires sociaux
soutien du medef et de l'ump avis
partagé des syndicats pressions de son
aile gauche françois hollande a choisi
ce contexte pour annoncer une prochaine
loi sur les licenciements dans les
entreprises rentables
un engagement de campagne pas du tout du
goût du patronat ça c'est une
proposition de loi qui est pour nous
inacceptable et même dangereuse en
matière de dialogue social le
gouvernement donne l'impression de
souffler le chaud et le froid
un calcul risqué premier élément de
réponse le 5 mars prochain avec la
manifestation de salariés à l'appel de
fo et de la cgt
voilà à pierre que l'agent du service
politique de l' agence france presse
nous a rejoint ben soir pierre donc vous
d'interroger les ministres sur cet
accord qui va devenir loi donc qui ne
passent applaudie par tous on l'a
compris sira vous savez un sévère que le
monde à soi même presque suspect a à cet
accord ambitieux ni c'est ce que celles
au réformisme de gauche pourtant
certains à gauche le critique disant
qu'il est trop déséquilibré en faveur du
patronat ou que c'est du social
défaitisme que leur répondez vous non
j'ai pas avoir entendu beaucoup de gens
me dire ça mais j'attends qu'il me le
dise en face c'est quoi cette cette loi
parce que aujourd'hui c'est un projet de
loi on ne parle de l'accord parce que
c'est un processus qui est très
important mais c'est un projet de loi ce
projet de loi c'est le projet de loi du
gouvernement de jean marc ayrault
portée par le ministre du travail michel
sapin juste pour que on ne se trompe pas
de personnalité en face de soi mais
c'est un processus la méthode est
quelque chose de très nouveau dans sa
réussite et de très important qu'est ce
que nous voulons nous pensons que si on
veut réformer en profondeur et il faut
le faire le droit du travail pour donner
plus de capacité d'adaptation aux
entreprises aux situations on a parlé de
quelques-unes
plutôt que d'attendre le dernier moment
pour régler ou ne pas régler le problème
pour compter le nombre de licenciements
il vaudrait mieux faire ça avant
prévenir les choses et faire évoluer les
choses et préserver le plus grand nombre
possible d'emplois
et puis de l'autre côté il faut
sécuriser chacun des salariés sécurisé
il donnait des sécurité personnelle des
droits à la formation des droits à la
couverture santé des droits à
l'indemnisation chômage qui soit
supérieur à ce jour si on veut réussir
ce type de réforme en profondeur ça ne
peut pas venir simplement d'en haut ça
peut pas simplement être une volonté
politique il faut d'abord regarder ce
qu'en pensent ceux qui connaissent
l'entreprise ce qui la dirige comme ceux
qui y travaillent donc il faut faire
confiance aux partenaires sociaux
là où nicolas sarkozy faisait siffler
les partenaires sociaux dans ses
meetings
nous nous leur faisons confiance pour
négocier et parvenir à un accord et ils
sont arrivés à un accord qui n'en
portent pas forcément la signature de
tous alors on les écoute ni les
opposants heureusement je les ai été le
premier à les écouter je voudrais
d'ailleurs ce moment mais est la moindre
des choses qu'on doit faire vis-à-vis de
ceux à qui on a demandé de négocier
c'est de respecter le résultat blanc
négociations alors seule la cfdt et deux
autres syndicats ont signé cet accord
donc avec patronat pourquoi ces trois
c'est plus que deux mais il manque quand
même il manque 3 c'est plus que de dons
pour une fois unis et sans la cgt et fo
le dialogue social ne reste-t-il pas
d'échouer
alors la cgt et fo quand je leur ai
demandé est ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour négocier sur ce sujet ils ont dit
oui nous serons autour de la table et
ils ont eu raison
ils sont arrivés autour de la table
est-ce qu'ils sont sortis de la table
pendant la négociation non ils ont été
jusqu'au bout la négation
ils ont eu raison je vais vous dire
pourquoi ils ont eu raison parce qu'ils
ont pu en pesant dans la négociation
obtenir un certain nombre de choses que
peut-être le rapport de force n'aurait
pas pu permettre d'obtenir d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qu'il me demande
ils me disent pas retiré le texte ils me
disent pas mais tu es tout gagné ils me
disent modifié sur telle ou telle prise
par torah c'est que c'est une régression
sociale mais ça c'est des paroles il
faut regarder le contenu de choix
parfois je sais que dans le débat je
n'ai aucun doute dans le débat est en
partie au débat au parlement
point par point mesure par mesure
proposition par propositions il est tout
à fait possible parce que c'est la
vérité de démontrer que ça va dans le
sens de l'intérêt de tous les salariés
mais ils ont participé à cette
négociation à la fin c'est normal c'est
ça le jeu de la négociation
il y sera globalement ça ne va pas bon
donc on signe préférées
mais bien sûr mais c'est pas moi qui
étais à la négociation
ensuite ma tâche c'est quoi ce qu'on
appelle souvent la retranscription ce
n'est pas vrai c'est l'écriture de la
loi c'est l'écriture de la règle en
s'inspirant et en respectant l'accord je
les fais et je les fais comment
loyalement vis-à-vis de ceux qui avaient
négocié et conclu l'accord et en
transparence avec les autres oui il
était aussi un matin et c'est normal
j'écris la loi pas seulement pour ceux
qui ont signé d'accord j'écris la loi
pour tous donc je propose à londres
tandis que alors bien sûr mais bien sûr
le dialogue continu avec eux si vous
prenez vous la cgt par exemple et force
ouvrière ont donc pesé sur le texte
retranscrit même si vous n'aimez pas ce
mot là mais ils ont pas je leur ai dit
exactement point par point mais c'est
mon sens du dialogue
je vais pas choisir les bons et les
mauvais toutes les organisations
syndicales pour moi sont légitimes
elle apporte quelque chose elle
représente une identité
elles ont un rôle ensuite dans les
entreprises mais je vais les un tout
petit peu floue et toutes les
organisations syndicales
quand ce texte sera devenue la règle la
règle nouvelle
la nouvelle règle du jeu dans les
anthologies sera voté oui quand il aura
été votée je n'ai pas de doute sur ce
point on va parler peut-être si vous le
souhaitez arrivait en france que vous
appelez les coups de boutoir dont j'ai
entendu une représentante de la delà de
la gauche madame d'amitié voilà mais
donc on donne la parole à une lente ce
qui est tout à fait normal et pis y'a
quand même les autres voilà il a tous
les tous les autres sur le jour le
testera mais gérer ça de côté les
organisations sérieuses tout les organes
social et tout particulièrement les
premières d'entre elles cgt cfdt et fo
vont s'emparer vont s'emparer de ces
dispositifs
ils seront les premiers à négocier dans
les entreprises parce qu'on donne un
pouvoir de négociation on donne un
pouvoir
aurore organisation syndicale dans les
entreprises considérable pour négocier
les accords qui permettent aux
entreprises de s'adapter aussi ils
seront les premiers
d'ailleurs comme le sont déjà
aujourd'hui ah oui mais comme il faut il
ya des négociations appellent ça en ce
moment
quelles vont être méditée les
signataires fo donc voilà verrions je
peux vous prendre d'autres exemples où
c'est la cgt qui fait partie est fier
mais c'est normal je les prends pas en
défaut au contraire je les prends en
train d'agir de défendre les intérêts de
ce qu'il représente c'est ce qu'ils
feront demain avec les nouveaux outils
que nous l'aurons cgt et fo ont annoncé
leur intention de manifester le 5 mars
la veille à rien de manifester c'est
normal attendez vous dites quoi une
posture alors il maniait vous dit vous
négocié avec lui au téléphone et puis
son compte en effet des mesures qui vont
prononcer que sur dénonciation je ne
vais pas parler à leur place
ils disent qu'ils ne sont pas contents
je parlais de retourner les chérie tu
étais pas celle-là en découdre mais la
vérité elle est beaucoup plus subtile
elle est beaucoup plus complexe et on
peut être en désaccord avec un texte
dans sa globalité et ensuite être
républicain et avoir qu'une seule idée
c'est qu'au bout du compte lorsque le
texte devient réalité s'en emparer pour
le faire vivre dans l'entreprise
éditrice nation sociale à la suite de la
position très ferme de la cgt dont la
source est question de ses pas sur ce
texte là les crispations sociales qui
existent les tensions sociales qui
existent elles existent sur des dossiers
dont nous avons parlé il ya quelques
minutes
parce que je le répète quand vous êtes
confrontés à la fermeture d'un site au
licenciement de plus de 1000 salariés où
que ce soit il ya de quoi être tendu
donc la tension sociale elle et elle est
présente elle est légitime elle est
normale et nous devons faire avec
non seulement faire avec mais accompagné
aussi de trouver les solutions ou
parfois dans certains cas les moins
mauvaise solution
mais c'est pas à propos de cet accord ou
en tout cas du projet de loi que je
porte que je redoute des tensions
sociales
bien au contraire je pense que ça sera
vraiment une
adra des capacités de mouvement des
capacités de négociation des capacités
pour peser aux organisations syndicales
qu'elles n'ont pas aujourd'hui leurs
tensions sociales révèle peut-être
d'avoir tensions politiques et au
parlement quand ça va se passer et
quelle est la consigne c'est pas tout
chaud quelle sera la marge de manoeuvre
de discussion c'était très étrange cette
vision comment dirais-je et
disciplinaire du débat démocratique
moi j'étais député depuis très très
longtemps j'ai commencé j'avais 28 ans
g12 j'avais un droit d'amendement batou
députés et sénateurs a à droit d'un
moment il est reconnu par la
constitution
on va retirer le droit d'amendement
parlementaire ça va pas possible et
c'est pas souhaitable c'est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus important que ça ce
qui se passe ce qui se passe je vous le
disais d'ailleurs est ce qu'un
gouvernement qui est favorable au
dialogue social qui demande aux
partenaires de négocier et qui
constatent qu'un accord peut remettre en
cause cet accord
non sinon il y aurait un défaut de
loyauté c'est pas la peine de demander
aux organisations syndicales et
patronales de négocier si au bout du
compte on respecte pas leur accord mais
vous l'avez améliorer le texte vous ne
l'avez expliqué furent les députés
veulent les mêmes droits alors
l'amélioration du texte me pose
absolument aucun problème à personne
mais je le répète autrement rendement
mais jpa parlementaires jouent ce rôle
j'ai pas le jai pas comment dirais-je
l'outrecuidance de penser que mon
écriture serait la seule possible et la
plus performante mais simplement mais
simplement que dans le simplement il ya
beaucoup pour le parlement c'est comme
pour le gouvernement
qu'est ce que ce serait qu'un parlement
globalement est très majoritairement
favorables au dialogue social favorable
à la recherche d'accords être compromis
qui dirait il ya eu un accord je m'en
fiche
non pour un parlementaire s'apaisent
c'est un poids ça une importance et
c'est ça qui va aboutir à ce que les
parlementaires un patio les
parlementaires de gauche département de
terres socialistes et qu'une seule
vision c'est de respecter l'équilibré
d'un accord mais respecter l'équilibré
d'un accord ça veut pas dire ne pas
amender une phase est toujours visible
d'amélioration de tels amendements
comment quelles sont les pouilles avant
de taizé novembre quand j'écris le tec
j'ai le sentiment de faire le meilleur
texte possible oui et aux autres d'être
intelligent jugé intelligent que moi ce
qui est parfaitement très facile que
vous cherchez que ce texte peut encore
être meilleur
il peut certainement être mieux écrits
mais on aimait l'art dans les écrits
c'est pas bien d'écriture mais c'est sur
les mesures auraient fait là je peux
répéter les choses sans foie il ya un
équilibre dans l'accord toute volonté
gouvernementale ou parlementaire de
mettre en cause des équilibres serait
mettre en cause le processus lui-même
c'est pas la peine de redemander une
autre fois à des partenaires sociaux de
négocier si on ne respecte pas leur
accord aujourd'hui deuxième chose nous
sommes dans un avant-projet cet avant
projet il va bouger encore on va au
conseil d'état le conseil d'état il ya
des gens extrêmement compétents
extrêmement pertinent est extrêmement
intelligent et les trois fois plus
intelligent que moi même quand il s'agit
d'analyser le caractère juridique
d'intel
il y aura sûrement des améliorations qui
seront issues du conseil d'état et si
ensuite devant le parlement
il ya des députés extrêmement pertinent
qui disent sûrs tels bois ou sur tel
autre
on peut améliorer la rédaction il ya une
ambiguïté il faut éviter une chausse
trappes il faut éviter que je sais pas
quoi il ya ensuite un contentieux
judiciaire
hugo initial est inutile et donc on va
essayer d'améliorer les choses
moi j'ai aucun problème c'est ce que
j'ai fait avec l'accord il y avait des
parties dans la corne qui était ambiguë
ou qu'ils étaient incomplètes tout le
monde le disait c'était en bio
incomplète j'ai pris mes responsabilités
et c'est ambigu moi ça devrait être
ambigu dans le texte donc je dis les
choses je vérifie avec ceux qui ont
négocié si ça respecte l'accord mais
c'est respecter équilibres il bout du
compte ils me disent oui vous avez fait
des choix vous avez respecter les
équilibres
c'est comme ça qu'il faut donc ne l'a
pas touche à l'équilibré du texte mais
vous êtes ouvert à des améliorations
mais le conseil d'état moi j'ai
longtemps rêvé à celle gta par le manque
encore longtemps le débat parlementaire
aura lieu mais avec ce qui est très
important c'est pas une contrainte à
cognitique j'ai pu lire ou géopolitique
on peut pas être favorable au dialogue
social
si on ne respecte pas le résultat de ce
dialogue social d'accord c'est simple
non ah oui ça y est on a tous bien bien
bien compris et surtout si vous vous
adressez aux parlementaires de voter
j'ai surtout certains j'ai rappelé notre
confrère cité 5 vous serez là peu près
au bout de votre compte
et puis il ya combien combien il ya de
députés combien et sénateurs socialistes
voilà bah vous faites le calcul d'un
goûter le team de quel côté se trouve le
respect du cadet des aides sociales
dernière question au réformisme social
démocrate que vous défendez passe par le
dialogue social
êtes vous confiant sur la poursuite et
le développement de cette méthode des
négociations dans les profondeurs
on a pris là on a mis sur la table les
sujets les plus délicats les plus
difficiles qu'il n'avait pas été abordée
dans tous les cas de manière
constructive et et victorieuse depuis 40
ans c'est la première fois depuis 40 ans
qu'on met sur la table les sujets les
plus difficiles que les partenaires
sociaux sont en part et qu'ils arrivent
à un accord et c'est la première fois
qu'on va avoir une législation qui n'est
pas rien
c'est une saison c'est un gros textes on
va réformer en profondeur et on va
permettre aux entreprises au lieu
d'avoir ce réflexe aujourd'hui dès qu'il
ya un problème de dire combien jean
licencient et bien de travailler
autrement ça va être
comment j'évite d'en licencier comme
enjeu je discute plus tôt comment j'ai
pas d accord avec les organisations
syndicales dans l'entreprise
ça va être dialogue dans chaque
entreprise pour très énervé l'emploi
pour développer l'emploi et pour
sécuriser chacun erreur vous rendez
compte le champ nouveau et c'est tout
moi donc ça a marché
pas encore je réponds à la question oui
la question c'est est-ce que vous allez
continuer ça a marché
on va continuer oui ça c'est sûr on va
même constitutionnaliser le dialogue
social c'est une manière de montrer
combien on attache de l'importance à
cette manière de faire qui est qu'on ne
décide pas tout au niveau central pour
bien voir réformer la société
il faut aussi compter sur la société
d'en bas et ça c'était un désengagement
de françois hollande durant la campagne
justement la principale revendication il
respecte c'est la négociation sociale
c'est aussi une grande prix sur les
questions de loi sur les sites rentables
ou à une valeur de contre les
licenciements ou d'un mot d'un mot c'est
une grande victoire aussi pour françois
hollande ça ajoute à ses galons de chef
de guerre au mali ce sont des domaines
différents un homme et pauline sont des
domaines différents il est dans son rôle
de président de la république lorsqu'il
s'agit d'engager les forces armées il
l'a fait avec maîtrise et avec succès au
mali et puis il ya le l'emploi l'emploi
l'emploi l'emploi la lutte contre le
chômage ça durera pas quelques mois
l'emploi et la lutte contre le cheval
c'est vraiment verte qui cela que nous
sommes tous tournés et pour longtemps
merci caire d'avoir est avec nous ce
soir dernière partie de preuves par 3
avec perrine tarneaud de public sénat
pour parler de vous aujourd'hui michel
sapin vous aujourd'hui et demain quand
l'ami depuis toujours de françois
hollande est bien notée dans les pages
politiques des journaux
françois goulens neuf mois deux
ministères et un bilan sans fausse note
michel sapin le fidèle parmi les fidèles
du président hollande a su affirmer son
autorité au fil des dossiers alors même
que les chiffres du chômage flambe ses
compétences font presque l'unanimité
chez ses interlocuteurs du medef
à force ouvrière un talent de
négociateur que son ami le sénateur jean
germain connaît bien et je pense qu'il
une
profonde croyance dans dans l'être
humain et pas de jugements à
l'emporte-pièce qu'il rencontre un
syndicaliste cgt qui dit que les
socialistes sont des pourris des vendus
c'est pas pour ça qu'ils ont décidé de
pas discuter avec lui considère que
voilà ça fait partie du jeu sa proximité
avec françois hollande et son dévouement
aux idées sociales-démocrates du
compromis ont développé chez le ministre
du travail
un sens aigu du pragmatisme on ne peut
pas convaincre sans prendre le risque
d'être convaincu
je pense que c'est ce qui peut lui
arriver aussi il ya un moment même s'il
arrive avec une position par
l'élaboration collective probablement
est-ce qu'ils changent de position lui
aussi qu'il est convaincu
et ça je pense l'avoir plus d'être
toujours sur la position la plus
efficace et la plus pertinente au moment
où il la défend michel sapin maîtrise sa
communication avare de déclarations
lorsque son homologue du redressement
productif multiplie les saillies cette
discrétion ses détracteurs la voient
comme un manque de courage voire un
calcul politique n'entend quasiment plus
monsieur sa passe est clair qu est-ce
qui fait il commente les statistiques du
chômage mois après mois pour dire wild
chômage s'est encore aggravée t'es
peut-être d'une technique mais regardez
paradoxalement dans les dents les cotes
de popularité c'est plutôt montebourg
qui montrent que sapin donc c'est pas
forcément une tactique efficace avec ce
profil de ministres dévoué et discret
michel sapin est cité parmi les rares
premiers ministrables de l'équipe
actuelle il jou cependant gros en raison
de l'importance des défis qu'ils doivent
relever
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage et
la création de cent mille emplois
d'avenir
le tout d'ici à la fin de l'année 2013
safa qu'est ce que vous répondez déjà à
marc philippe daubresse qui dit que vous
manque un peu de courage politique
mais voilà il ya au moins une personne
qui disent du mal de moi oui ça me
rassure vous ne trouviez que leur
partage était trop rien de trop c'est un
reportage fait par des journalistes que
je respecte et des ports mais que ce
soit marc philippe daubresse
d'aujourd'hui je l' ai connu à l'écouté
est connu dans le dialogue et je crois
qu'il a un peu mal tourné mais très bien
une personne a dit du mal de moi tant
mieux le monde du week-end vous placer
dans la catégorie des valeurs
du gouvernement héros est ce que ça vous
laisse de marbre vous ces classements
entre bons ou mauvais ministres vaut
mieux avoir ce type de commentaires que
l' inverse
mais en même temps je sais que tout ça
va et vient que ça fait partie des
commentaires de l'actualité
ce qui compte dans un gouvernement c'est
pas de vouloir réussir individuellement
même si on préfère que ça marche pour
soi c'est de ce qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour tous
pour l'ensemble quelle place on a dansé
ensemble cible c'est une vraie équipe
on peut avoir des moments 10 ans et si
j'ai marqué le but tout seul ça va être
super non c'est pas vrai certains jouent
solo dans le gouvernement comme dans
tous les gouvernements oui mais c'est
toujours c'est toujours un exploit des
personnalités qui sont ainsi plus
heureusement si si un gouvernement était
fait uniquement de petits pois comme
dirait l'autre qui se ressemblent les
uns les autres on s'ennuierait et on
serait pas efficace donc il faut un
ailier droit ni les gauches un
avant-centre des piliers à l'arrière
bref donc il faut une vraie équipe avec
des personnalités d'ici là en plus j'ai
pris une image qui dénie machecoul se
meut liste et qui est une image qui
était une image de rugby ça marche pas
donc moi je veux trop prendre une
métaphore ça ne fonctionne pas mais être
au sein d'une équipe et jouer pleinement
mon rôle dans cette équipe
oui ça me va à l'épicerie où je sais
qu'une seule volonté c'est que la
présidence de françois hollande
réussisse et que lui-même réussissez
réussir ça veut dire quoi que ça change
pour les français cela que la réalité
que la vie quotidienne des français
puissent s'améliorer alors qu'on est
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
donc la loyauté avant tout en ce moment
la coqueluche et de la gauche et des
médias c'est christiane taubira
ovationné personnalité exceptionnelle et
ovationné cet après midi pendant près de
trois minutes dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale après l'adoption
du texte le match pour tous mérité vous
dites oui oui parce que nous on a bien
vu là la puissance parfois la
mesquinerie des attaques et y compris
vis-à-vis de la personne
un début dans le gouvernement interdira
oui parce que les femmes parce que elle
est issue de la diversité comme on dit
elle est noire et donc immédiatement on
a bien vu qu'il y avait un regard
particulier qui se portait sur elle est
bien là montré qu'elle avait des
qualités exceptionnelles bien supérieur
à beaucoup de ceux de qui on avait voulu
abandonner la critique et elle a su dans
ce débat difficile sur le mariage pour
tous porter une voix portait une
conviction et le faire avec respect ce
qui fait qu'au bout du compte vous avez
vu ce débat où il ya plus de français à
la fin du débat qui sont favorables au
texte qu'au début d'habitude c'est
toujours l' inverse
et bien elle a une force de persuasion
telle qu'elle a convaincu un grand
nombre de français que c'était une très
belle et bonne loi une loi de progrès
une loi d'égalité
vincent peillon je vous rassure on va
faire tout le tour du gouvernement mais
celui qu'elle en ce moment sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires il y avait
aujourd'hui des grèves des
manifestations assez important dans
l'éducation nationale est-ce qu'il a
péché par excès de confiance
non mais dès qu'on touche au dispositif
de l'éducation nationale c'est très
compliqué puisque vous avez beaucoup de
professeurs de chacun a une vision de
son propre rôle parfois compréhensible
vous avez beaucoup d'élèves et vous avez
presque autant de parents d'élèves ou
même presque plus de parents d'élèves
donc ça fait énormément de monde je
connais pas de ministres qui quand il
prend une décision touche à autant
autant la vie quotidienne d'autant de
monde donc des vous toucher à quelque
chose d'important
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué que c'est
difficile absolument donc on n'est pas
condamnée elle à remobiliser en avait
donné au conservatisme et sur ce point
où l'intérêt de l'enfant n'est discuté
par personne et c'est ça on avait
l'impression pendant la campagne que
c'est l'intérêt de l'enfant les mercis à
leur personne
et oui mais le jour où le fait chacun y
voit un petit inconvénient c'est bien
dans sa vie est un manque de
concertation voulue au lieu de voir le
petit inconvénient que chacun peut
ressentir
il vaut mieux voir le grand intérêt
qu'il ya pour l'enfant pas de rencontre
de concertation
non il ya eu des concertations sans fin
il a eu plein j'ai moi j'ai participé
aux états généraux qui ont permis de
définir y compris une grande voile avec
une programmation qui va être qui va
être bientôt discutée et tout le monde
était d'accord pour dire celles prévues
préjugés
l'intérêt de l'enfant le jour où on
arrive dans la réalité c'est difficile
il faut continuer à dialoguer dialoguer
expliquer montrer qu'il ya des solutions
parfois il ya des vraies difficultés qui
sont mises en avant
1 combien de temps va durer la période
pendant laquelle l'enfant ne sera pas en
place
quel va être l'accompagnement comment
les collectivités locales vont elles
pouvoir faire face à tout ça ce sont des
vraies questions et elles vont être
résolus je vois dans ma petite commune
d'argenton sur creuse et bien piqué oui
bien sûr victime dès septembre 2013 on
met en place les moyens pour ça et vous
verrez les paroles bah oui moi j'essaie
d'être bons élèves parce que j'aime
beaucoup les élèves et je pense que
c'est les faits michel sapin sur
françois hollande
au delà de l'homme qui a certainement
changé évolué avec avec la fonction est
ce que ce ne sont pas les regards sur
lui qui ont évolué ces dernières
semaines comme envoyer des gens moins
depuis qu'il est présent avec lui qu'on
ne regarde pas quelqu'un qui devient
prison la république comme celui qui
était là auparavant c'est normal il ya
un respect d'ailleurs pour la fonction
il ya une admiration pour la
responsabilité qui changent
effectivement le regard et puis il ya
depuis quelques semaines oui voilà c'est
depuis quelques semaines au fond vous
avez la conjonction d'un certain nombre
de choses alors heureusement sont fait
pas la guerre tous les jours je dis
heureusement parce que décidé de
l'engagement de troupes s'est décidée du
risque pour ses troupes et iris compris
du risque suprême pour ses troupes et
puis c'est décider de la mort aussi
d'autres ceux qui sont en face et qu'il
faut disent les militaires avec des mots
toujours alambiqué anéanti retraités oui
m'enfin c'est la mort bon donc
c'est de ce sont des décisions
extrêmement difficile et qui
effectivement montre que françois
hollande peut être au même titre que
d'autres présidents à d'autres moments à
ses capacités de décision de prise de
décision extrêmement puissante qui
applique y compris la vie la vie des
autres donc c'est vrai que de ce point
de vue là on a vu grandeur nature sur un
sujet comme celui de chef des armées
il ya beaucoup d'autres sujets on voit
maintenant la continuité on voit la
cohérence de cette politique ça commence
à se voir
ce qu'au début on fait une réforme est
en forme c'est pas que ça tâtonne et
difficile au début
non mais c'est pas que cette attaque
mais c'est que on met en place une
réforme on commande cette réforme on en
met en place une autre en commando très
fort mais il ya andré nous tout ça est
cohérent on veut que les économies que
nuit française fonctionne mieux
donc il fallait que les entreprises et
plus
de capacités d'intervention
d'investissement c'est le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi mais il faut aussi
qu'elles surmontent ce que françois
hollande très intelligemment appelle la
peur de l' embauche
parce qu'en france il ya parfois une
forme de peur de l' embauche il faut
surmonter cette peur de l'envol c'est ce
que nous allons faire avec le texte sur
la sécurisation de l'emploi
donc voyez que tout ça est cohérent et
quand on stabilise l'europe quand on met
en place au niveau européen
un sérum de programmes en faveur de la
croissance on est dans cette cohérence
et cette cohérence est en train de se
voir une dernière question sur votre
ministère michel sapin vous êtes
interpellé dans une vidéo et par une
pétition qui a été signée par 130 mille
personnes par des travailleurs du
dimanche par des salariés de magasins de
bricolage qui vous demande la poursuite
de l'ouverture le dimanche de ses
enseignes qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez chien mais qu'il faut respecter
la loi mais pourquoi certaines enseignes
de bricolage est ce que vous demande
sont plus passant de droit national ou
indivis d'autres qui voudraient dire
sous prétexte que j'ai pas respecté la
loi donnez-moi le le droit de ne pas
respecter la loi ne sait pas on ne peut
pas fonctionner comme ça dans une
société
aucune société bras quand un feu héros
jeudi le feu est rouge
et cela parce que quelqu'un a brûlé le
feu rouge que je vais lui dire tu as eu
raison de brûlé le feu rouge
enfin où il répond si on allait comme ça
certaines enseignes par exemple d'un
doublement des jardineries en droit
d'être original parce que certaines
enseignes ont respecté la loi ont
demandé il ya eu des autorisations avec
ses des zones qui ont été dé la l'on
n'ait jamais oui qu'est la loi donc ils
l'ont respecté et d'autres ont dit ça
sert à rien de respecter la loi de toute
façon après coup ça sera régularisée je
ne sais pas moi gérer une société ne
serait ce que le monde du travail en
fonction de volonté qui consisterait à
dire je brûle le feu rouge
donnez-moi l'autorisation des feux
rouges non il faut respecter la loi qui
n'empêche pas de négocier de discuter ou
par des évolutions possibles mais on ne
doit respecter l'homme et c'est pas vous
qui respectent pas la loi
eux ils sont salariés d'un certain point
de vue ils sont un peu prisonnier dans
cette affaire ben non c'est la direction
qui doit respecter la loi
michel sapin ou est-ce que vous voyez
demain si vous remportez la bataille de
la france comme a dit jean-marc herr
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la bataille de
l'emploi et d'ailleurs elle a remporté
vous l'avez dit les cours vont
s'inverser à la fin
fin de l'année où est ce que vous voyez
premier ministrable le mot était cité
tout à l'heure dans les reportages non
mais moi je me pose absolument pas ces
questions et en plus je considère que
c'est le poste le plus difficile le plus
fatiguant le plus éreintant de la
république ne réussissent pas vous ne
voulez vous pas c'est peut-être le
meilleur moyen non moi je suis très bien
là où chi jeu merci c'est le boulot
n'est pas terminée merci à vous merci
perrine bonsoir à tous la semaine
prochaine valérie pécresse sera notre
invité
gyan histoire et son apparition sur la
scène publique il fait preuve d'un
talent d'un charisme qui en font un
porte parole idéal il a tenu ses
promesses en faisant une belle carrière
même si le premier secrétaire du ps est
aujourd'hui critiqué justement par
certains pour son manque de charisme
alors y at il une manière de faire de la
politique quand on est jeune quels sont
les thèmes et des discours qui permet
d'émerger et comment on se comporte et
les têtes d'affiché aujourd'hui à leurs
débuts cette semaine des as millions en
tout bien tout honneur les jeunes
pousses d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
déshabillons-les samedi à 23h45 sur
public sénat j'ai affirmé que la grande
priorité du prochain quinquennat sera
l'école l'éducation
je revendique les 60000 postes
d'enseignants de surveillants
d'assistantes sociales d'infirmières
nous avons besoin de 150 mille
professeurs pour l'essence pour les cinq
années qui viennent pas pour les
professeurs pour eux mêmes mais pour
former des millions et des millions
d'enfants nous avons douze millions
d'élèves scolarisés aujourd'hui dans le
système ils sont la france de demain
l'école de la république grandes
priorités affichées du quinquennat pour
réfléchir au recrutement et à la
formation des professeurs jacques
bernard magner sénateur du puy de dôme
et ancien enseignant a dirigé pendant
quatre mois un groupe de travail
objectif nourrir la future loi sur la
refondation de l'école grâce à une
trentaine d'auditions au sénat et à des
déplacements dans différentes académies
il y a donc trois grands objectifs
d'abord de retrouver un vivier qui
permettent d'assurer la pérennité du
métier d'enseignant parce que pour qu'on
a des enseignants il faut qu'il y ait
des gens qui va ici former ensuite
retrouvé une base sociale plus large une
assiette sociales plus larges du
recrutement puisque on voit bien que
pour le masters il ya une forme entre
guillemette d'embourgeoisement de ceux
qui bénéficient de ces formations et
enfin une meilleure formation tout au
long de leur scolarité jusqu'au master
de ceux qui seront dépensés dont le
gouvernement ayrault souhaite recruter
massivement et vite
cent cinquante mille enseignants dans
les cinq prochaines années cela
correspond aux 54 mille créations de
postes promesse de françois hollande
pendant la campagne présidentielle
auxquels s'ajoutent les presque 100
milles départ à la retraite qu'il faudra
compenser une urgence de recrutement que
partagent les personnalités auditionnées
par le groupe de travail les besoins de
recrutement on le sait ce sont et seront
considérables pour diverses raisons et
en particulier raisons démographiques
c'est pas tout à fait maintenant ou
jamais mais je me sens que des travers
toute la concertation y ait le sentiment
très fort que il fallait effectivement
mon été à un moment clé est que ce qui
ne se seraient pas maintenant ne serait
peut-être pas après que si on veut
préserver une certaine idée de l'école
puisque de ce qu'est l'école dans la
société
il fallait évidemment aboutir et réussir
prix
une situation très perceptible sur le
terrain à 1500 euros nets en début de
carrière après cinq ans d'études
les candidats ne se bousculent pas au
portillon anaïs crapet est une de ces
nouvelles professeurs stagiaires cette
année à villejuif en banlieue parisienne
après avoir réussi son concours l'an
passé sa matière les mathématiques est
l'une des plus frappée par la crise des
vocations à titre du chapitre opérations
sur les nombres en écriture
fractionnaire les grands l'an dernier
près d'un tiers des 950 postes ouverts
en mathématiques n'ont pas été pourvus
et ce sera sans doute encore le cas à la
rentrée 2013
une image dégradée du métier et des
conditions de travail peu attractive
décourage nombre des tirs au but de la
réforme tout en maintenant cinq ans que
tu pour devenir professeur de
mathématiques avec le même niveau de la
thématique exigé au bout de l équivalent
de la licence on peut aller faire une
école d'ingénieurs alors c'est sur le
temps de travail n'est pas le même mais
le salaire non plus donc ça peut
expliquer la crise des vocations en tout
cas dans les mathématiques ça c'est sûr
et puis cinq ans d'études c'est
dissuasif aussi rien cinq ans d'études
il faut les financer
on les fait dans des grandes villes qui
les mathématiques lettres anglais
allemands ou encore musique
nombreuses sont les matières où les
besoins de recrutement ne sont pas
comblés dans le secondaire l'école
primaire n'est pas épargné les syndicats
enseignants tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
sur la chute vertigineuse du nombre
d'aspirants au cou il ya six ans il y
avait on va dire 3000 candidats qui
postulait pour les postes premier degré
sur une petite académie nkom poitou
charentes aujourd'hui on en est à 200
donc la question du vivier elle se pose
aujourd'hui très sincèrement elle est
parfois très très grave y compris dans
des cas limités ont toujours été stable
et attractive pour raviver la flamme de
l'enseignement chez les étudiants le
ministère a lancé une grande campagne
d'affichage dans toute la france est axé
son discours sur la priorité donnée à
l'éducation et donc à des emplois
sécurisé en pleine période de crise
je lance aujourd'hui un appel solennel à
la jeunesse française
nous avons besoin de nouvelles lumières
républicaine nous avons besoin de
nouveaux hussards noirs
nous avons besoin de la jeunesse
française pour redresser la france est
ensemble bâtir un autre avenir mais
aucune recette miracle n'émerge pour
attirer les étudiants
au fil des auditions au sénat il ressort
pourtant que c'est peut-être du côté de
la formation que l'accent doit être mis
certains professeurs n'ayant jamais vu
une classe avant d'exercer le
recrutement précoce des enseignants
c'est une manière de préparer aussi des
enseignants qui ne découvre pas le
métier en ayant le concours ce qui est
évidemment le drame actuel et c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui je suis à
l'iufm de bordeaux vous dire les jeunes
sont dans une situation de désarroi réel
et profond et non seulement ils sont peu
nombreux mais en plus on crée les
conditions pour que éventuellement il
raccroche
avant même d'avoir commencé les
auditions s'enchaînent et des pistes de
formation précoce font leur chemin
pourquoi ne pas imaginer